[Music]
hey folks
welcome back to the dark horse podcast
live stream number 47
q and a section all right here we go
cats over our shoulders we are ready to
answer some questions that's right
uh so we'll start with a couple of
questions from episode 46 that we didn't
get to
before moving on to a question that
comes out of the discord
server this week and then moving on to
last hour's questions before moving on
to this hour's questions
first up will atheists and secularists
at large be able to effectively apply
the memetic level of group cohesion
experienced in religious groups with the
tools needed to bring this about
necessarily need to be religious in
nature
yeah that's a good one uh problem is
some of the tools
have been housed over in religious space
can the atheists
the modern atheists pull off the the
feats necessary
probably not on the other hand you can't
very well have a system
that is predicated on people believing
in rewards and punishments in the
afterlife
that uh those who discount them will be
freer to engage in
various behaviors that are antisocial so
we're stuck we have to figure out how to
do this in
a secular and atheist context
and i would say in some sense the tool
for doing this is
pretty obvious what we have to do is
actually
structure the incentives of the system
so that pro-social
behavior is actually rewarded in the
long term and then we will see it
elaborated by
selection if we do anything short of
that then the disbelievers will have an
advantage over the believers
and things will come apart
good uh this next one did you do you
have anything to say on this or should
we
skip it um yeah a little bit okay
um excuse me uh what are your thoughts
on the world economic forums the great
reset
discussions this is something that we
both only know a very small amount about
yeah i i have not delved deeply i've
looked a little bit
and so the basic idea is that covid
reveals
fragility in the system and we all ought
to talk about
um what it is that needs to exist in
order to make the system
more robust and anti-fragile and i agree
with this
i'm not sure how much i trust the world
economic forum
to have this discussion um i'm
encouraged that they're interested in it
but i would say the question is
in some sense the right one but uh
when the so-called stakehold holders are
the ones that the world economic forum
holds dear
there's a question about how useful the
solution they're going to come up with
is because there is a real problem and
so
is this in essence the status quo
realizing far too late that it has left
us in a vulnerable position
and negotiating with us in order to
retain its position
some level yeah i think so um but at
another level it doesn't mean it isn't
the right question
yeah and just this question began with i
didn't read it because
i seem to butcher the pronunciation
every time is it shana tovah yeah
we are now this question came in last
week here now between the
um the highest holidays in judaism i
think that yom kippur
starts uh either tonight or tomorrow i
don't remember
um and and rosh hashanah the new year
was last week protests have largely been
fueled by us versus them thinking
would your podcast ever consider adding
nuance to this by interviewing a police
officer
yeah absolutely i would interview a
police officer i would
interview a protester and in fact i have
had preliminary contacts with
both so anyway maybe i should uh restart
those discussions and see if i can't
make it happen
yeah especially given that uh here in
portland uh the fires and the smoke
appeared to have put um a mere
very temporary and not even a complete
halt to
uh what was going on in the streets here
but uh they resumed with full force
as soon as the rains came a week a week
ago yep
uh there's a cat right behind your chair
so don't should i be frightened i don't
it doesn't look dangerous
what do you know about hampshire college
in massachusetts and how does it compare
to evergreen
uh yeah so hampshire was one of um
five i think colleges in a consortium
along with evergreen along with new
college in florida
pitzer college in uh socal
was maybe colorado college maybe it was
the other one i can't i feel like i'm
not
sure that it was colorado college that
was the that was the um
additional member there um but they're
all experimentally
pedagogically experimental liberal arts
colleges
everyone that i mentioned um except for
evergreen is private
actually new college might be affiliated
with the university of florida system
i'm actually not sure about that but
hampshire's private
um and so you know it's
i think its model is fascinating it is
on the verge of collapse as many liberal
arts colleges
are because while it has a
really remarkable model of empowering
students in which students are
potentially empowered to do
uh terrific independent and creative
work what that means and this is exactly
the problem we saw at evergreen
is that it also allows people who are
lazy
and um have no interest in doing
interesting work of any sort
can kind of skate by without even having
to meet any basic requirements
um so you're talking about students yeah
i'm it's true of faculty too i'm sure
well i don't know any faculty hampshire
but
i saw that at evergreen we saw that
there were faculty were highly dedicated
and there were other faculty who
got hired and were impossible to get rid
of yeah did nothing no but um
we saw we saw we saw that less directly
with regard to the students at evergreen
because our students tended to be
motivated because
um because there was
very high demand for our programs and if
you didn't want to do anything you could
easily find that in other programs and
not
not in ours i'm just i'm assuming that
really at any school
now you can find a way to get by with
doing almost nothing
but it's going to be easier at one uh
that have specifically thrown
many of the traditional um requirements
out the window
and i think hampshire has done some of
that as evergreen certainly did
and there are virtues to that there are
advantages but it does mean that
it's easier to game the system if you're
interested in gaming the system if you
if you want to throw away your tuition
money and come away with a degree
but no education you can do that easily
at a school that has no breath
requirements
you can do it at another school too but
you can do it anywhere but
you know hampshire had supreme promise i
do think it may not be around
in five years yes my recollection is it
has been on the financial rocks for
many years yeah um i would also say that
one of the things that is true and you
know we uh both graduated from santa
cruz
which was experimental one of the things
that's true for
but also a an r1 like santa cruz is also
a research one university with
tremendous amount of uh you know federal
funding for big research
so it is both an experimental liberal
arts
thing inside a massive research
university
right um so the analogy that
it has with evergreen is that it was
public yes
so let's just say all of these things
are failing in one way or another maybe
colorado college
isn't it might be the one example that
isn't but
i suspect pitzer isn't either um just
because it's part of the consortium down
there in the clermont colleges and i
don't know that they
look out for each other financially but
you know being
in a consortium with claremont mckenna
and harvey mudd and such it's you know
it's
it's the sort of you know wacky liberal
arts
um one but it it's it's all it's a
cluster
in the same way that there are like
clusters of
strangeness at santa cruz but there's
also a lot of amazingness
it's a cluster but it may not be as
clusterfucked because at one level
you can go to pitzer if it sounds good
to you and take classes elsewhere if it
doesn't turn out
right so and that's the same as just
hampshire actually hampshire is part of
that consortium a different consortium
of five colleges that includes
umass amherst and amherst and smith and
mount holyoke
i think it's going to be the five there
so that's that's a kind of uh protection
you know an experimental model yeah that
allows students to participate
very much at different degrees is useful
um the thing that was missing from all
of the others
that evergreen had that i thought was
absolute magic
was the full-time programs
right the when you as faculty are
full-time in one class and your students
are full-time in one class and that
class can go on for a full year
it means that the relationship between
professor and student and between
students and each other
is totally different than a regular
college and what it means is you can do
a kind of teaching that can't be done
in a regular college and you know to be
sure there were more faculty at the
point that we were at evergreen there
were more faculty doing nothing with
that opportunity than doing something
but if you wanted to do something it
allowed you
in my opinion to teach uh in a way that
was effectively custom
tuned to each student which you and i
both did
well we knew our students well we cared
about them and
it meant that you could think about what
each person in the room was hearing
you know who has trouble with this kind
kind of concept and what needs to be
said so that they get it
um you could you know not be so
regimented to
what you plan to talk about that day a
concept that turns out to take longer
than you think it's going to can
can expand to take up more more space
all of those things were like magic
for professors that wanted to push the
envelope of what was possible and for
students that were not a good fit for
normal school
because they could get um a kind of
education that just wasn't available
to the extent that they were an
anonymous person in the room so yeah
now um just one little nuance here is
colorado college
like a number of smaller less well-known
colleges
mostly scattered throughout the um the
midwest i believe
do have something called a block system
right where they do full-time
um full-time i don't think they call
them programs but for three
three weeks at a time so at evergreen
you had 10 20 30 week
programs uh and colorado college for
instance i think has eight of these
three week blocks a year
and at any given moment you're only in
one thing with that class and that
faculty for three weeks
but they 100 always guaranteed end at
the end of the three weeks
and you don't continue um with that
professor in that learning community
into the next
to the next block so um it i imagine it
hints
at some of this um power but it can't
get all the way
no um i will say at the point that
evergreen was looking rickety to us we
just happened to give a talk out of
colorado college and it was the one
model that was different enough
from normal that i felt like maybe maybe
that's actually
something i could do right it was very
hard to imagine
walking away from the beautiful freedom
that we had at evergreen and
the amazing community that it allowed us
to build but
it would be interesting to figure out
what you would do with a block
intensively and so how can you you know
get up to speed in time and do something
interesting and then move on to
something totally different that'd be
fun
yeah i mean you wouldn't end up forming
the deep relationships with students
probably um but you could potentially do
a kind of
educational experimentation where you
know i think faculty teach
you know four or five of the eight
blocks a year making that number up but
it's certainly not all eight
um because they have governance and they
have research expectations and all of
this
um but you know if for instance you were
like okay i'm gonna do
i'm gonna do three iterations of this
thing this year
and um you know especially interesting
maybe although this just makes it less
well controlled but you know if it's got
a field component i'm gonna do one in
the fall one in the winter one in the
spring
and you know the thing that makes it
entirely uncontrolled always
is if the students are different the
program is different it just is i don't
care
how much you think you're just
delivering the same information into
empty vessels who are students
no the students are going to respond
differently to different material
and it could be very interesting to
notice how things change
with a different complement of of
students when you're actually
sort of trying to do the same thing
repeatedly yeah
yeah i the i have some dread over the
idea
repeatedly from the idea that you're
supposed to run the same lab
several times which was always a
nightmare you know i
almost never ended up doing it because
it was so nightmarish but
i did yeah one one year i taught a three
three person program
um and it was it was i was doing
vertebrate evolution including
comparative anatomy and systematics i
was teaching systematics and so i was
doing computer labs for just a few weeks
uh teaching them
aspects of i don't remember what mclaid
maybe and
whatever the actual powerful systematic
software was at the time
and the way we had it each of the three
faculty had
each of the three groups of students um
that day so like for three thursdays
running i had to teach the same lab
three times and you know it's
systematics which is just um you know
it's actual origin of species stuff like
how do you actually discern differences
um relationships in history you know
that uh
when i when we make the claim that
mammals and birds separately evolved
endothermy on what basis do we make that
claim so it's
it's it's that sort of it's that sort of
thinking um
and it would seem perfectly tuned to a
really dull and dry
analysis but who wants to do that and
it's not interesting and this is
life this is the evolution of life it's
so exciting and wonderful
but um truth be told the third time in a
day you're going over
um why it is that you're walking
students through um you know building a
data set of characters and taxa for a
lab
it can begin to seem pretty pretty
tedious yeah i mean
you know amazing as he was even god only
did it once
that's a pretty good joke
all right where are we we are at the
discord the question that came out of
the discord
server this week voted on there
what are some of the major blind spots
of modern medicine how can an
evolutionary approach the human body
ameliorate these shortcomings and what
are you currently seeing up to where are
you currently seeing optimism in this
regard
little question guys thanks for that
well um
so also answered your question in your
question which is marvelous
the fact that evolutionary biology
shows up so lightly in medicine and
almost
not at all in clinical psychology and
almost not at all
in dentistry or ophthalmology is the
problem
right this has such huge implications
for the way the body works and therefore
the way the body
fails it has huge implications for what
we ought to be
doing differently to prevent pathologies
rather than always playing ketchup and
trying to treat them
so the big flaw if i remember your
question correctly
is the fact that these fields have not
been updated for darwinian thinking
period and the opportunity is
immense why does no medical school teach
from a darwinian perspective
it would it would be the dominant
medical school almost instantly if it
figured out how to do it
so um this is the subject of um
two depending on how you count of the
chapters of the book that we are
working on the third draft of right now
specifically what is it that medicine
has done right and how
is its evolutionary blind spot
manifesting and how therefore as users
of a medical system as most as all of us
are
can we better understand our own health
and make better decisions and help our
doctors make better decisions for us
zach if you would put on screen uh for a
moment just this paper just came out
weird bodies mismatched medicine and
missing diversity
by a guy named michael girvin who i
don't recognize but also daniel
lieberman
who's who was the chair i don't know if
he still is the chair of department of
human evolutionary biology at harvard
he also wrote an extraordinary book that
i used to teach with called the story of
the human body
and and he's also i believe a long
distance runner and so specifically his
has a research focus on um
skeletal and specifically foot formation
in early human evolution and whether or
not
long-distance running and walking um
helped form our modern
skeletons with all of its uh pros and
cons he's also the
famously barefoot long distance runner
am i correct
i am i think so but i'm not positive
about that
let me just say one more thing about
this so this is this is a good paper
that i recommend that has some of the
answers to the question weird bodies
mismatch medicine and missing diversity
we've talked about weird before
here but that weird is an acronym
standing for
western educated industrialized rich and
democratic so it's a stand-in for
you know rather than just saying you
know the west uh which isn't
a totally accurate description of um
what
set of demographic and cultural
parameters are
that are descriptive of having the kinds
of remarkable blind spots especially
evolutionary blind spots that
many of us have all right all right
um next question trump's move to halt
critical race theory training is both
bold
and the timing seems almost enlightened
have we been underestimating his
intelligence or does he have an
intuition that helped him make a smart
move in an opportune moment in history
yeah i mean we've in fact i think you
mentioned last time at the time before
that we've
i've called him a political savant and
and was calling him that not
at the point of the last election but
fairly shortly after that um at which
point i could
you know at that point i hadn't seen
anything to recommend him
at all you know this move um this move
and others since i do see
i do see that he has made some some
moves that are not just politically
savvy but also
what i would say are the right moves um
so this this strikes me as perfectly in
keeping with that and you know is he
more than that is he more than a savant
uh this is this is something that you
addressed i think last time
well so i've been calling him a
political genius and i've been telling
the left that they need to wise up
because to the extent that they treat
him as a fool they keep underestimating
him
and handing him lots of tools
and also in this case as in some others
handing him the moral high ground which
is not something that the democrats
should want to do and yet they do it
again and again so in this case
we have the right move we have
the politically savvy move being the
same move
so we don't know what motivated this and
the question that i have
is what happens when a guy like trump
makes the right move and gets lauded for
it
will he develop a taste you know and so
yeah
can we train him our trump supporting
viewers will
bristle at this discussion because i
think you and i both feel that trump
is i would say an entirely cynical actor
which doesn't mean he's always wrong
that's right um but it means that the
motivation
is advancing the political ball this is
where his genius is
um but to the extent that the right
thing to do
is to i mean the only thing to do
is to take the most essential machinery
of civilization and immunize it from
this insanity
however you do that so this must be done
the fact that lots of us are looking you
know lots of us from across the
political spectrum who are paying
attention
know that the ship is being jeopardized
by
uh whether you see it as a psychotic
break a
emergent psychotic break on behalf of
the population an autoimmune disorder
um sabotage whatever you see it as the
answer is
you have to immunize the essential
features of
society from the you know from
gazing into their navel and wondering
what two plus two
actually equals right you have to stop
that stuff
and so he's done it and it's
a brilliant political move it's the
right move will he get addicted
to doing the right thing and having
people who are
in other parts of the political spectrum
that don't usually recognize him saying
actually
pretty good stuff right uh let's hope
let's hope yeah right i i certainly
leave that possibility open and i i hope
for and to the extent
that the democrats are going to play
their same damn card and their point is
going to be if trump wants it
then it's bad if they're going to play
that which is what trump is counting on
in this case
then they are setting up a situation in
which lots of people who know
how dangerous this belief system is and
what it is threatening to do
are now in a pickle which is you can't
vote blue because blue is inviting this
stuff through the door
yeah so they're creating there there are
plenty of existential threats to go
around
how dare they create a new one because
it serves them politically
well said
hello from another couple living in
panama city no relation to the guy from
last week
as far as you know that you know uh were
you sorry
evolutionary biologists tend to do
and actually if you go far enough down
the phylogenetic tree my guess is there
is a relation that's right
uh we are u.s citizens that have been
here seven years you're an oasis of
rationality we value your contribution
to the culture more than we can express
well thank you jordan thank you go have
some ceviche
at the yacht club in panama city for us
yeah
the yacht club is kind
well so you came to know the yacht club
in panama so you brett lived in panama
for 19 months
uh mostly living on baro colorado island
which is a island formed with the panama
canal was
formed it was it had been a dry hilltop
and now was in lake cartoon in the
middle of panama canal
administered by the smithsonian tropical
research institute and at one point
during your 19 months there
and i was there with you for for those
months or so uh
you discovered in my right that uh
you could if you just hung out at the
kind of diving yacht club
as smaller boats were trying to get to
the canal and they needed crew
you could be pulled to be to crew a boat
through the canal
i didn't discover this there was a bomb
i know you i mean you weren't the guy
who discovered it but if you personally
came to understand
i've discovered america and that if you
sit at the yacht club you can
be crewing boats in the panama well so
here's the thing the
yacht club is on the panama city side of
the canal it's right at the head of the
canal so actually the nice thing about
the yacht club is you can sit there and
you can watch the boats
lining up and the panama canal is not
what
any of us expect until we've seen it um
but the panama canal all the boats are
piloted by these
this elite crew of pilots who take over
the boats pilots
captains um i think they're called
pilots really yeah
um uh so anyway the big boats are
piloted by these
elite uh this elite crew the smallest
panamanians
yeah yeah they're panamanians um they're
not like american service members since
it's in the canal zone oh this was
after the canal i was there after the
canal zone had been turned over
um is that right yes that has to be
right
um but in any case the smaller boats
would pick up crew and you could post
your your details on the
the bulletin board there um and so i
never did it
okay i did have a license but you did
hang out in the diva yacht club and have
ceviche it was a good ceviche and it was
kind of a you know
decent drinks and anyway nice view you
could watch the boats lining up and
it was cool to watch their lights as
night fell and all that
um but anyway yeah uh i did have a
license to
navigate little boats on the panama
canal which was really cool
yeah do you still have that somewhere i
would hope somewhere
picture on my license is crazy
you have a lot of hair so much hair
right
it's really it's um yeah it's a picture
that if it ever got
out would probably change things so i
will say this
about your hair and panama that while
you were there
for for many many months and i had been
there or i was there with you
for four months or so near the end of
your time um but i was in madagascar
uh for many of those months and then i
was back in michigan
and at one point you were coming home
and
as it turns out you had been growing out
your hair for
all of the months because because i
don't know there wasn't a barber what
the hell
why the hell because if you're gonna
grow your hair out while you're living
on an
island isolated in the panama canal
where nobody's gonna see you it seems
like a perfect moment
and so you had not told me this though
and you came off the
off the plane with so much more hair
than you
had left with that i was uh i mean i i
recognized you but it took a moment
yeah that was like it it was uncanny
valley level
difference right a lot of hair it was a
lot of hair yeah yeah
okay um when gender-critical folks
say gender doesn't exist might this not
be shorthand for individual versus
population level differences
rather than blank slatism
wow i think you're giving people a lot
of credit um
yeah i think they say sex doesn't exist
they they love
the well who cares about the language i
think they can play
they confuse the language intentionally
but um
is it possible that some of the people
trying to wield these tools are trying
to do so carefully and might
if you presented them with that analysis
that it's individuals versus population
level
mean that maybe but i don't
the vast majority of them don't mean
that yeah and i would say
you know if you're if you're making a
subtle but correct argument
that that emerges as people challenge
you and you say
no i think you're hearing me incorrectly
this is actually what i'm saying and i
would say
i think the chances that you and i are
running into a
true nuanced argument that we have
failed to spot
in conversation after conversation is
pretty low
right we're pretty good at spotting what
a student means for example
rather than what they've said you know
pulling the value out of a question and
reframing it and so
we we would hear it if we were there no
i mean the level of confusion like okay
you can say it's just a tweet but that
one i showed in the last hour
about this the idea that trans women
which is to say natal men experience
period symptoms
and any naysayers should sit down and
shut up because not enough science has
been done like
it's so missing reality at so many
levels
like it just is incoherent there's no
like population versus individual level
differences there that person wouldn't
know what a population was if it hit
them in the head
i mean i you know i've gone through
periods and episodes
and uh you know i've had the occasional
era but um you've been hysterical
i have been hysterical you imagine that
um yeah etymologically that's an awkward
one for me but um
in any case going through periods isn't
uh now that you mentioned it yes it
it is awkward but um but yeah
the uh let's put it this way we can play
language games all day
yes but physiology games those are a
whole different level
well and that's and that's what's being
done on on to unwitting children in in
part
uh with the with the hormone blockers
and you know the idea that
puberty is optional this is a sign that
we've seen in some of the protests now
puberty is optional
no it's not yeah
any child young person even you know
of age adult who thinks that has been
woefully mistreated by the system they
just they got no education at all and
uh if you're a parent do not believe
this yeah it is
not optional it is uh unwitting children
who are being damaged by
half-witting adults
yeah i'm going with that yeah i like
that that's good that's good
if an immense giant wait what and my
trackpad has stopped working
okay so i can't even really see it
okay it's actually gonna do that i'm
gonna just like look over here mike here
if an immense giant thousands of miles
tall was in space
and capable of physically grabbing the
earth like a ball what would it feel
like to him
would it be heavy delicate wet hot
how would he describe it um
so still not working
all right i know i'm working on it i'll
try it unfortunately when it's off it
works and when it's on it doesn't
yeah that's good okay so
we're getting lost in trackpad i'm
trying to understand the question
we've got a giant yeah we got a giant
we've got a giant thousands of
miles tall in space capable of
physically grabbing the earth like a
ball wouldn't feel like to him so
thousands of miles tall does not
inherently get you it's still dwarfed by
the earth
unless it's it depends on how many
thousands of miles exactly so what's
that
what's the diameter of the earth uh the
diameter of it
no well let's see the circumference did
you just say three thousand seconds
yeah circumference is like 27 000 which
means that the diameter will be
something like a third of that yeah
yeah um so we would need tens of
thousands
to hundreds of thousands just we're
talking about like baseball-sized earth
then it's hundreds of thousands
but you also i mean there's no i mean
the giant himself is creating the
gravitational pull
right so the the giant like so there's
no there's there's the question include
the giant's gravity
it doesn't and so like he's just in
space which means
like what it doesn't feel heavy or light
like it's not
so the earth would stick
to the giant because the hand would be
similar in mass
to the giant's hand they would stick to
each other
gravitationally and presumably the giant
is now in orbit around the sun
right as the giant lifts the earth there
is a proportional movement presumably
the giant is many times the mass of the
earth
and therefore moves much less than the
earth but there would be some balance
between their motion as the giant moved
the earth
the giant is not standing on anything
right but i don't know what you mean
moves less like if the giant is holding
the earth they both move
as they move no if the giant
takes the earth and elevates his hand
the giant will move down
and the earth will move oh relative yes
yes okay
but there's the hand and the earth
removing the same right
giant by the way we're all dead now the
giant
yeah no and i mean the lack of a
gravitational frame like there's not
there's nothing else that the giant is
standing on
means that this this is where you have
to this is a
monstrously sociopathic thought
experiment in the sense that you have
just
killed nearly eight billion people in an
instant
and all the hippopotamuses
hippopotamuses okay i'm
not convinced it's not hippopotami but
either way they're dead
good point yes it matters it doesn't
matter now
but the giant will feel the earth as the
giant brings the earth
to himself so that's what he's doing no
it's a hymn we've we've been given the
giants
sex but gender isn't real it's his sex
also not real real okay you win
but as the giant brings the earth to
himself he will feel as if a magnetic
attraction why no yes gravitationally oh
just because of himself not because of
the earth
is too tight it's like i mean it's
really hard to imagine what it feels
like at so if we go it's a baseball
sized thing what does it feel like for
us to wield a baseball no because we're
standing on our gravitational field
references
here's the thing we don't intuit this
because gravity is so freaking weak
now i didn't decide to make it so weak
but it is weak right
it's coming after you now table has
gravity but you cannot
feel it right but the point is if the
table were earth scale
then its gravity would be appreciable
and the bigger it is the more
appreciable it is so a giant wielding an
earth
would feel that gravity as a kind of
magnetism
not much more than if he you know
decided to do
exercises and do a high knees you know
his knee coming towards his chest
together we have that same sticky nature
right which would decay with the
cube of the distance i think that's the
square maybe the cube of the distance
anyway
so it would be a an experience which is
what the question is about
that was dominated by the
fact of gravity being relevant at that
scale
where it is essentially irrelevant at
human scale yeah so would it would it
feel hot
well you haven't told us if the giant is
endothermic have you
well now interestingly so this is tough
because
the it depends on what homeostatic set
point the giant is at
as to whether or not the earth would
fill well what temperature would feel
not necessarily or not because what you
feel assuming the giant is the process
of an evolutionary force big enough to
make giants
then the giants would it be right that's
the only that's why i assume it yeah
the giant would be tuned to detect
the relative warmth and cool of objects
right where they net sources or net
sinks except this
is all taking place in a vacuum um
yeah but they're still conductive uh so
you can you can
you can have like tactile sensory stuff
in a vacuum
uh sure really
i am virtually certain i don't see why
you wouldn't i think you'd be
preoccupied with other things it's like
breathing but yes
right yeah i see no reason that you
wouldn't be able to detect
heat were you protected from the vacuum
but your hand out there in the vacuum
i think that works um yeah you could
detect something like heat but
so here's certainly you could detect
something like wet so yeah i think it
would feel
wet yeah yeah some parts more than
others
um but here's the question
the center of the earth is molten true
due to gravity the gravity of all of the
weight of all of the various pieces of
the earth
pressing in the pressure on the center
causes the molecules
iron in the center to be rubbing up
against each other and we're going to
start
moving out when it's this close to
another giant gravitational force
now that's a problem that is going to be
a problem the molten core is going to
start bubbling to the surface as it
tries to
as it tries in its unconscious
gravitational way to
uh be attracted to the to the giant's
mass yeah the crispy outside and the
chewy center is a problem now but um
so the question is suppose the giant was
a careful giant well
we can hope we can help actually it
doesn't much matter we're all dead
that's true but if the giant were to
treat the earth carefully so as not to
squish it
would would the giant feel heat
from the core what i'm trying to figure
out before it started to bubbling
below the surface yes if the center
oozed out
you'd feel heat but is the earth net
warm as a result of the heat released in
the center
or is that a concentration that is not a
net
is it not a net release of heat
yeah i mean compared to the the
bleak coldness of space i suppose it
would be net warm even before
the core started to burble to the
surface i think so but i'm not going to
be surprised if one of them physics
types contacts us
and says you've got it wrong yep yeah i
have a phd in giants holding the earth
and i can tell you that
totally totally by the way we hope to
hear from you
one of my favorite assignments that i
used to give uh back when
i had a regular job when you gave
assignments back when i gave assignments
um was that i would tweak the parameters
of the earth and i would get my students
to predict
what the evolutionary consequences of
those tweaks would be so imagine that
you had an earth that was a cube
so that as it rotated you had a hard
edge that would cause day to show up
and disappear you know like this um
[Music]
i don't think a hard edge would be
sufficient for that you still have an
atmosphere
still still going to creep right well
this is exactly the sort of conversation
that we would have
um so you could do things like you could
change the tilt you could
uh make two suns you could oh this i
mean this kind of world building is what
i was doing when i was
creating my science fiction universe and
yeah totally yeah
and then there was the the granddaddy
puzzle which i should unveil
at some point um in which i had a series
of islands around the equator of a
planet
and set an evolutionary puzzle in motion
at one side of the planet anyway that
was one of my favorites
yeah this is sort of like that it is
this is sort of like that yeah maybe at
some point we can
speaking of past assignments talk about
the fraternities my
fictional family of uh beetles which are
haploid diploid but in which the sexes
that are haploid and diploid are
reversed having cascading effects on
social
behavior that was a tough assignment
right it's fun though yeah
when people when people used to claim
that evergreen
was a place with no academic rigor i
used to think back to your assignments
of that nature
and think they weren't talking about you
yeah or you
yeah true okay uh where are we ah we did
giant
we did giant and now we're on too
could any high-powered equipment being
used by those fighting the fires
be the cause of the interference um i
don't
think so strongly doubt it and i mean so
much of the firefighting here
was like they were pretty close they're
remarkably close given that we are
in a a major you know not a giant city
but we're in a major metropolitan area
and they were remarkably close
uh but so much of the firefighting was
very low tech it was about creating
um you know barriers to to the fire
transmitting further
not remembering all the name all of the
work language that the firefighters are
using but
a lot of it was digging fire yeah yeah
so the only way in which i could see
something like this
contributing is if you had and i don't
know that this
ever happens with firefighting i assume
it does not
but there are these flying i'm
forgetting what the name of the aircraft
is these flying command centers with a
giant
uh dish on top
um for high very advanced uh military
missions there used to be one parked at
um
up near the flight museum uh at boeing
field all the time but anyway
such a plane uh
conducting communications with a large
group of
ships other planes etc potentially could
do something along that lines
you could even have a military option
operation where there was an intent to
disrupt communications of the enemy
but none of this has anything to do with
firefighting so i think
even the planes that would be used you
know these very dramatic
uh things that have uh fire retardant
that drop it on
fires i don't think would be doing
anything electromagnetic that would be
having
this influence but it is you're right
the one thing that does line up is it
would
explain the temporal phenomenon except
that
the fires continued after the reigns
yeah so i think we've just fallen
although i mean they they got less
intense like
the fires they they the the great they
are saying that the fires aren't going
to be fully put out until the end of
october
um because there is basically such such
thick detritus
um in which there are pits of heat uh
some of which are reaching 1200 degrees
fahrenheit
that are still smoldering um even just i
mean still i think in clackamas county
which is just one county away from us
uh and you know some of some of the fire
suppression efforts now and this the two
biggest ones closest to portland are
still only
as of yesterday it was like 30 and 35
contained something like that i'm making
up those numbers but it was something
like that
um and a lot of the firefighting efforts
in advance of the rains that came again
yesterday the day before we're basically
digging up these pits to expose
some of these you know heat pits to the
rain so that that could begin to cool it
off but
they weren't using it it doesn't look
like
i think anyone's imaginings you know
stereotyped imaginings of what
firefighting looks like
right now anyway yeah
have you seen michael moore's new film
planet of the humans it's getting a lot
of heat from both left and right about
corruption and the green energy business
i haven't seen it i don't even know of
it not me either um
i uh we watched some michael moore stuff
back in the day and then at some point
it became a little hard to watch
um you know good probably 10 15 years
ago it seemed a little bit
uh too one-sided interesting if this is
getting heat from both sides
i don't i don't know more than that
next question the police kill about a
thousand people a year
in contrast there are about 250 000
medical malpractice deaths per year
and people of color have high medical
mortality
should we start a movement to defund
doctors
yeah um yeah i wonder that 250 000
medical malpractice deaths
um seems high to me um but i'm sure it's
more than a thousand i'm sure it's it's
more than the number of
uh people killed by police every year
yeah you know i have seen some of these
uh
yatrogenic harm numbers and they i don't
remember their staggeringly they are
staggering which you know i think we
have to be careful because
you don't want the number to be zero
right
because basically you have no medicine
at that point well and just just
it's a it's a harder thing to say but
i've actually heard um
i think i've heard sam harris say this
right like you don't want
uh the number of people killed by police
to be zero
either right right because that's airing
too far in the other direction well
you've either that's a problem that it's
basically impossible to say right now
but um but for any of these things where
there's you know there's tragedy there's
individual human tragedy reducing that
to zero means that you will create a
whole other kind of tragedy which
doesn't yet exist
um in its in its wake yeah i think the
easy way to see this
is we could reduce highway deaths to
zero
easily with current technology right and
they're really two ways to do it
either you prevent all driving or you
uh set speed limits so low and so that
the requirements for vehicles so high
that nobody could possibly injure
anybody you know if we're all driving a
tank at two miles an hour
right then you can get highway desk
pretty low
pretty quick yeah sounds like a party it
does not and so the point is we've all
made this decision
right yep probably you don't go out and
say what is the
safest possible car i could buy right
you say
oh that's a very safe car and new
parents are more likely to veer in that
direction and this is why we have these
like stereotypes about
the kinds of cars that new parents buy
but even then
even then you are much more likely to go
to consumer reports
and see oh this one gets a five-star
crash rating
rather than the gas economy like the
mileage is terrible
and right right but you know so lots of
people will go with i want a five-star
crash rating but they won't go you know
if
some car that has dismal this or that
happens to be safer they often will not
buy it because we all
calculate that okay this risk is
sufficiently low that now some other
parameter is
um more important and you know of course
there is an interaction
if you buy a car with cruddy mileage
because it just so happens that it is
the top uh
you know the safest car well then that's
going to cost your
family in terms of how much resource it
has based on how much you're spending
and so that will have an interaction you
know potentially the quality of food you
buy or something else so
you know even if you're dealing with
health as your top consideration
it's a complex equation yeah um but
so i mean the point which is um could be
read as a glib
is is a a good one right like
for any of so just to read it again the
police kill about a thousand people a
year in contrast there are about 250 000
medical malpractice debts per year
and people of color have higher medical
mortality should we start a movement to
defund doctors
it's it's a perfectly
analogized point pick anything where
there are deaths that that you don't
want to happen
find that there is disproportionate uh
death in some demographic that has been
historically underserved by a system
and argue that that entire system should
be defunded as a result because the only
possible reason which is you know
implicit here
the only possible reason that there
could be disproportionate effects
on an historically uh disadvantaged
group is
modern racism yeah systemic racism ism
whatever
misogyny transphobia fatfi whatever it
is it's a
beautiful point i would like it even
just one step better if it was
abolish rather than defund because
yeah the real point is nobody
nobody including those of us who are
very focused
on yatrogenic harm nobody believes that
medicine
is inherently more harmful than it is
beneficial
right it does lots of harm lots of it
unnecessary um
and therefore preventable but you know
the idea that abolish is the next step
is a non-sequitur just as it is with the
cops
yeah um
so i don't think you've heard this i'll
read this question but um
vincent uh i don't remember how to
pronounce him
resaniello rightfuniello on this week in
virology
episode 664 argues that sorry's cove ii
could not have originated in a lab
have you heard his argument would you
consider interviewing him do you know
him do you know
that name don't i have heard many such
arguments
i believe they all come apart
i'd be curious if there's anything to
recommend this argument
there's certainly a lot of pressure for
anybody who can generate an argument
that
casts suspicion away from
the wuhan institute but anyway
let's put it this way i would consider
interviewing him but i want to know
that he is something other than a shill
before i would decide to do it
next question my daughter asked me if
fire is alive
i said not but she argued that it covers
all of the mrs grand criteria
so why isn't it i must admit i'm stumped
please help my four-year-old is
outstarting
outsmarting me thanks so this
question invokes mrs gran allen capps
i'd never heard this before i figure
this is some
have you heard this mrs grant so this is
going to be some as it turns out it
looks like
uh usually elementary school although
maybe where is
my safari why can't i find anything on
this computer at the moment
um yeah i find it
um in basic biology uh
it is it is an acronym that you don't
have to show the sec
this is just some rando site it's it's
some i guess
elementary school level acronym uh that
is being taught to people and so this is
this is interesting
um the idea being that
students are being taught that living
things display certain characteristics
seven things beginning with the letters
in mrs grant
movement respiration sensitivity
control homeostasis growth
reproduction excretion removal of waste
products
and nutrition taking in of nutrients and
food
so this strikes me as um both being
rather more complicated than used to be
and also missing some
some key things um
and i don't know if we want to just uh
speak to
whether or not fire is alive and go at
it that way but uh
your update to dawkins for things
um that are um clearly products of
i don't know if it's evolution or
selection um
four characteristics necessary for
adaptive evolution
um so dawkins characteristics were four
characteristics that cause a pattern
so he wouldn't put it in these terms
yeah this is the slightly updated
version
things that cause a pattern any pattern
to be
at its level of commonality so whether
that's the number of gold atoms
in you know on earth or the number of
spiral galaxies
in the universe there are four
characteristics
off the top of my head they would be
tendency
to come into existence
the similarity
the persistence once created
and then the fourth one is the tendency
to accumulate
stuff limiting stuff yeah and so
this gets transmuted in the context of
uh selection and adaptation
by um by heredity which causes
adaptation to take place so
those processes are basically
selection and then you add heredity and
it causes cumulative selection to make
adaptation
so add heredity and you get uh you get
life or is that not sufficient at that
point
um well i have to say i'm not sure
i'm not sure why we want to be
the exercise of define life and then
find the edge cases that throw you you
know what are we going to do with prions
okay well but we but this isn't an edge
case fire isn't alive so
so so uh this person's four-year-old
said why isn't fire alive it covered it
satisfies these seven criteria that i
was taught
are the criterion for for living things
and i look at this list and say well
that's a list of things
but it actually isn't as elegant as it
could be
and fire isn't an edge case it's
actually just not you know prions and
viruses we can
talk about but fire is not alive so on
what basis are we so certain that it's
not even an edge case
i'm not so i a why is movement on that
list
does something have to move in order to
be alive i i don't know that that's a
rule
i can't see why it should be unless
you're going to include growth
in movement in which case you would
almost by definition have to grow to go
from
essentially no dimensionality to more
dimensionality
yeah so like i said i don't i think this
this acronym is not
um as useful as it might be but can we
can we
either describe why it is clear that
fire is not alive
and or generate a better
uh simple rubric than than this one
where i agree the very first letter
um is for something that doesn't seem to
to be right and
um but you know respiration um
also you know this the second one fire
is
um consuming oxygen but it's not
engaging in gas exchange so exactly
something we talked about in
in the last hour right like fire is not
engaging in gas exchange
it is consuming um consuming
something consuming oxygen um
but here here's why i'm resistant to the
exercise
to even describing why fire isn't alive
yeah okay
um though i agree fire is absolutely not
alive um
imagine it's your four-year-old asking
believe me
as you know i talked to both of my
four-year-olds this way
and they're now 14 and 16 are still
speaking to you so although excruciating
at times it did work
yes it seems to have done it seems to
work here's the problem
at some point there was no life and some
process and we can talk about what that
process might have been
then there's something that is clearly
alive right and then
between those two places there is edge
case
so just as i don't
it is certainly true that you know a
chicken and egg question
is not a real question because we know
that the first chicken
whatever it might have been came from an
egg
all right i'm perfectly happy to say
that that is logically required
we couldn't have done anything but come
from an egg because all of the ancestors
that are definitely pre-chicken also
came out of eggs and all of the
descendants that
came from it came out of eggs so coming
out of an egg is what it did the egg
preceded the chicken
do i want to get involved in defining
which step in you know
the route between the pre-chicken
bird ancestor and a chicken it's become
a chicken
that seems like a fool's paradise to me
so the fact that we can logically say
that there are certain things that are
true
and that given any definition of chicken
there must have been a first one
and it did come from an egg all those
things are true but
then which one was the first chicken is
a question i don't want to be
responsible for because i know it's not
answerable
and so so i get all that that makes
sense but fires fire and life aren't on
a continuum with one another
eggs and chickens are in a continuum
with one another they exist in the same
history and on the same
life timeline i agree fire and life
aren't i agree but the point is at the
point that
we as biologists say here are the
characteristics
that are required for life we are then
up against all of the places in the
universe where life will obviously have
evolved and it will challenge these
characteristics
and so recognizing that that's coming my
point is there
isn't really a um
uh a set of criteria that are okay so
put aside the criteria
is it rock alive no is a quasar alive
no is fire alive no how do you know um
well for one thing
uh they didn't come about through the
process that would guaranteed
be at their origin which is
an evolutionary adaptive process okay
so that sounded almost like a definition
well no because
as we just described the number of
quasars in the universe
is the result of the four
characteristics that will
dictate how common a pattern a quasar is
and it is a prerequisite to life
to which you would have to add something
hereditary
right quasars do not beget quasars
quasars do not beget quasars
um and therefore
the point at which you've added enough
hereditary component that quasars start
taking on the characteristics of life is
going to be arbitrary
right you're going to have to draw a
threshold and it's going to be arbitrary
so
[Music]
the other thing i would say maybe this
is maybe this is what you're looking for
um the characteristics that tend to
accompany
life is not the same thing as the
cinquan non of life
the cinquanon of life is
the attempt to persist
yes and fire doesn't give a damn
it doesn't care whether it persists or
not and just so
caring is uh evolutionary shorthand
for uh how's that drive to is selected
too
right there's that need be no
consciousness we are not impu
we're not ascribing consciousness to
slime molds or to
psilocybin mushrooms or just salmon uh
right but uh
they they drive to persist which
involves both survival and reproduction
and fire is uh is doing no such thing
let's put it this to this way if we look
at some slime molds a good example
okay slime molds are critters
that forage independently it's an oozy
forest critter that breaks apart
and forages independently which gives it
certain advantages
and at the point that it detects that
it's about to run out of food
there's a chemical signal that causes it
to reconvene
and fruit so that spores which are
capable of
escaping the patch that is now about to
run out of food
try to find another patch that may be
the most beautiful description of slime
molds ever
thank you um but the point is if you saw
fire doing this
as fire let's say you see fire a brush
fire okay
brush fire is climbing a hill right as
it gets to the top of the hill it knows
it's about to run out of fuel
right because it will have burned the
stuff on the side if it were alive
it would know somehow right we can know
we can the fire does not know you don't
know that no yes now i've just stepped
in
yes i do okay if the fire behaved as if
it knew
yes if the fire went into a very uh
ember generating form at the point it
climbed to the top of the hill because
it was about to expire for lack of fuel
and those
um you know jumping embers were more
likely to make it onto some other hill
and you could say actually it's behaving
as as as if it were alive
and then yes although i mean evidence of
selection acting on it is obviously not
the same thing as being alive this is
the point you have made
repeatedly with regard to say that you
know the the organization of
rocks on the show on a seashore that
they
um that they organize by size not
because they are alive not because they
have any intention of liking to be with
rocks of their own size but because
the physical forces of the waves provide
a selective force
so it is not the evidence that selection
has acted on them that would suggest
life in the case of a fire that act in a
self-preserving way
as it got to the top of the hill is the
evidence of adaptation
yes right so
somewhere in there it is the clear
evidence that adaptation accounts for
the pattern
and how would you detect adaptation is
behavior
in a manner so as to arrange persistence
so i don't think that there was hardly
anything
in there that you know we we may well
have talked to our children when they
were four like that but
even they because they were accustomed
to being talked to like that from
a very young age i don't think would
have really tracked that so i would say
to tim
who says his four-year-old is
outsmarting me um
presumably you could you could track all
of that or you'll be able to if you
listen to it again
um but i don't hear anything in there
that's actually easy to explain to a
four-year-old so
let me let me say it this way
you've got complex systems and complex
adaptive systems okay complex systems
include things like fire
weather right these are phenomena that
have complexity to them
but they do not have adaptive
capacity those things that have adaptive
capacity
are things in which purpose
is evident right the purpose
of a cat is to produce more cats now
ultimately the purpose is for the cat
lineage to persist into the future
but nonetheless the cat behaves in a way
that is purposeful
and my point about fire is the fire if
it behaved in a way that was purposeful
if fire was living and we just didn't
haven't figured that out yet
then it might behave in a way so that as
it faced extinction at the top of the
hill it arranged preservation through
some sort of reproductive
feat right and the point is the fire
climbing the hill will behave exactly
the same way
even if that hill leads to another oops
to another hill
as it would facing its extinction so it
does nothing to arrange its persistence
yeah the slime world has an interest in
persistence not that it could tell you
that
right a fire has no interest in its own
persistence and it also couldn't tell
you that
right but the behavior can tell you that
um so
we're over an hour already my goodness
we haven't even got oh boy
you you should you should have told us
something man um
okay uh do let's do two more here and
then try to get to
several um on the next live stream on
the next on
super chat from right now should the
military get involved in the event of
post-election unrest um
and then separate question did you check
household electric current quality
radiation would affect the neighbors
with precision electronics too so i
don't think we ended up talking to our
neighbors during the smoke down
uh i certainly attempted to check it i'm
limited with respect to tools
um but i don't think there was anything
to our electric power oh in fact we know
it wasn't electric power because we
tried
everything on battery and even when we
were completely disconnected from
um from electric current coming from the
wall we still have the same problem
that's right you did you did try that
yeah okay should the military get
involved in the event of post-election
unrest
depends on the unrest oh boy yeah and i
mean there's there's going to be unrest
no matter the outcome
um but you know you know i feel like
both sides
have uh have now seeded the idea that uh
we shouldn't trust the outcome
yeah it's coming from both sides they're
setting us up it's it's a disaster it's
almost
as if they suck beyond all recognition
almost no actually we're there we're
there yeah they suck beyond all
recognition
yeah yep yeah a while ago some of us
came up with a drinking game for the
streams
if someone says something can get them
canceled you drink
what do we call it no suggestions that
we came with up with had overwhelming
support
a drinking game for the streams which we
call it if you say something you get
if you say something they could get you
canceled you drank if you say something
that could get you cancelled
you drink so i'm gonna we may think on
this and come back to yeah
uh yeah i i want a little room on this
one yeah okay
uh so let me find this hour's super chat
if i can do so did you draw a line
thanks
thanks love um
okay this one is a little hard to read
try using unity2020 with all lowercase
because lowercase letters mean the date
is uncalibrated
hh you married a koi fish watch the cats
around him
what i don't know don't answer on amash
or chloe then you have them
on dan karlin and tulsi wink x2
okay alcohol joster it seems like it's
possible that your
your youtube name suggests something
about uh what you've been
doing before you asked the question i
don't i just don't know i mean i think
it's i think it's in good humor but i
don't know
i don't know what it means i don't know
what almost any of it means yeah
um do you guys have thoughts on prop 16
in california
you guys are awesome love the show gosh
i don't know what prop 16 which one is
that i don't know
i think it's that's when we know about
but i'm i'm hesitant
oh is this going to be we're not going
to guess
i'll i'll try to come back to this one
when we do have when we do know actually
what it's what it is
albert's going to look it up while i
slowly read the next question
from our friend holly mathnerd asks
seeing non-idiots argue that trump is a
wannabe dictator
even after his covet response was that
not a damn near perfect falsification
if so what the [ __ ] um
so did you hear that question i did are
you too immersed
um having trouble getting my device to
behave
yeah uh yeah his covered response was
was terrible um and i'm not sure that i
want to be
like i i've never thought he was a
wannabe dictator um so i'm not in that
camp but um
i'm not sure that his really terrible
coveted response
is totally incompatible with him being a
dictator and i say that as someone who
doesn't think he wants to be a dictator
um i mean just it would it would suggest
that he was incompetent at it
right but it was also a missed
opportunity for a would-be dictator
that's why i'm saying he'd be
incompetent like he missed the
opportunity to
but i mean dictate i think the point is
a dictator would be looking
for a crisis with which to justify
an authoritarian remake of this that and
the other he'd be looking for emergency
powers and he'd be
um yeah yeah although i mean he could
also see presumably like you know
one of the things actually in his skill
set presumably is
um you know he it appeared that he was
much more focused on the effects on the
economy than it was on the effects of
people who would be affected by the
by the pathogen and
um a dictator doesn't dictate for long
and a totally failed economy so
i don't know i don't know what emergency
powers he would have
used um while also keeping the economy
going strong i don't know it's
it's such a mess it's a mess but i do
think that there's something to be said
for the fact
that a dictator of one stripe or another
you would have expected a different
response to covet than we saw
which was way too political and inept
but
didn't look like somebody looking to
grab power yep
did you look up prop 16 or were you not
able to i wasn't able to find it
if if you like maybe um i asked the
evergreen
question a few episodes ago just wanted
to thank you both for the detailed
response
you both seemed a bit somber answering
it my apologies if it brought up any
negative emotions
love you both now we're we're good
thank you thank you we're good yeah 2020
is really
bringing up so many negative emotions
that really anything you did on top of
that is
liability no no it's this this person
asking a question about evergreen
i mean i think for me more than brett i
think it
thinking about what it was makes me
wistful you know i i
i still do miss parts of what we could
do there
and and the life that we created for
ourselves and our children
and um and uh to have it
taken with uh no apparent
choice no he he kept it under control
all right he's being responsible
um was uh it's
it's still a little bit heartbreaking
but well
there's nothing there now that i would
recognize i'm
wistful for what it was but i am aware
uh of what it has become uh
i think it was so nasty to us as it came
apart and so
duplicitous and disloyal that
um no part of me wants to go back the
part that mattered was the students and
we're still in contact with a tremendous
number of them and
anyway yeah so yeah
um maybe so maybe we should yeah why
don't we just move on and we'll come
back to it
next time what do you think about humans
what do you think
about humans diet evolution i imagine a
balanced diet wasn't attainable for
people through most of human evolution
our humans got biome specialized to
their region for instance our russians
better adapted to eating potatoes
so this is another chapter in our
upcoming book one which i just edited a
couple days ago in the food chapter
um the very short answer is
there is no single diet that is best
adapted
to humans it is going to be impossible
because we have evolved in many
different places in many different ways
you take a mediterranean diet to which
mediterranean peoples are presumably
well suited and you try feeding it to
someone
who is inuit and they are not going to
be as healthy as they would if you gave
them a diet
primarily of seal um not that many
modern inuits would necessarily want a
diet entirely of seal but
uh there are going to be differences
there are
um there are adaptations to an
agricultural lifestyle that are present
in
almost every extent human at this point
we have
i think the number is a copy of an
allele
that converts amylose which is the
starch molecule
to its constituent parts to sugars
through the enzyme amylase
i believe that chips have three copies
of this allele and that most human
populations have five
suggesting that we are actually well
adapted to this that you know the idea
for instance a paleo diet
in which we only eat animals and leaves
is the only best way to be human nope
wrong
is it healthy for some people sure
absolutely are there some diets that
people are eating now that aren't
absolutely but there's not going to be a
best diet for all humans nor is there
going to be a best diet
for you even across your lifespan
because you you will change in your
needs as you
as you age so with respect to the exact
question we cannot say whether or not
russians are better adapted to eat
potatoes but probably they are well
adapted to drinking potatoes they do
seem to be yes yes better at least
adapted than most of the rest of us
yes to the point of ending up under the
table
later
i'm interested to hear you two talk [ __ ]
literally
i've heard the stomach is evolving
faster than any other organ
also number two is a daily process but
it is rarely discussed
is there any gut biome information we
should all know
so i've never heard that the stomach is
evolving faster than any other organ and
both of us tend to distrust
um such analyses it's sort of like um
you know
re-upping your immune system with
various techniques um but
you know the the easy the easiest
simplest approach
to this question i guess would be 20
years ago
we really thought most medical
professionals and scientists who were
thinking about the human body thought
that humans were just individuals
and it turns out that we contain
multitudes right it's a biblical
reference but it's just true that we
contain
i don't have any idea what the order of
magnitude is but um
more than hundreds of thousands i think
um of
microbes um in our our guts on other
places that
help us uh process and digest and types
of microbes
uh no i was i was talking about numbers
i don't i don't think that we have
hundreds of thousands of species of
microbes but i don't know
but the order of magnitude of the number
of individuals is
absolutely astronomical it's close uh i
believe
to the number of cells that we have in
the body by virtue of the fact that the
microbes in question are bacteria and
therefore
very tiny relative to our cells so we're
talking about
trillions so certainly more than
hundreds of thousands
yep um i i am not sure about that number
but
like i said i don't even know how to get
close on the order of magnitude um i
don't think it's hundreds of thousands
of
species of types um i don't think it is
either but
um you know we now know that this is
true
about our for instance our gut
microbiota our microfauna
but we still don't know most of what
that means about
how we should be keeping that gut fauna
healthy
and and how else we should be
you know eating and drinking and and
[ __ ]
so that we are the healthiest so
uh one thing that is certainly true is
that it is worth thinking about
where those gut flora come from
right we are colonized very quickly uh
on
birth and what we are colonized by
has a big implication on how well we
function and so it is possible that by
virtue of the fact that we live in
novel circumstances in which people get
colonized in novel ways by
haphazard sets of of bacteria
results in you know a lifetime of misery
for people that we don't even notice
again this would be a perfect place for
medicine to get darwinian and to
discover
you know i mean we are increasingly
seeing stuff like fecal transplants and
things for people who have
yep mismatched gut flora and i would say
the farther you go down this road the
more you're going to discover that there
is uh
an important we are doing something that
is the opposite of fine-tuned
and there is an important fine-tuning to
be happen and probably
um once you have the right flora
treating it properly cultivating it by
feeding yourself stuff that it's
naturally well tuned to
yeah eating ferment and such yeah
as scatman crothers says in the
movie version of the shining
uh what does he say he says yeah
um something like
you're gonna have to be regular if
you're gonna be happy or something he
says that
he's touring them seems like a
lighthearted line from the shining
well it's early in the shining before uh
you know
all work and no play made jack a dull
boy um but yes gatman crothers his
character
um is um touring them through
the overlook hotel and showing them the
kitchens and i don't know
showing them prunes or something he says
something like that
uh just one one more comment on this uh
you had mentioned
that uh the process of being born uh
effectively provides
a number of of the microbes that you
then have in your early life and it
actually
presumably colonizes uh your life for
good and so this suggests that two
things of modernity are going to be
affecting our
gut fauna and presumably our health as
well and those two things are c-sections
uh by which you do not get uh you do not
get bathed in all of that gut fauna um
or it's not gut
out but you do not get bathed and yeah
in
the the fauna of your mother that you
would be and also
um cleansing the baby immediately after
being born and before being handed back
to the mother which is done in most
medicalized
birthing settings is presumably also a
way to dampen
the gut fauna and potentially
disappeared forever
trans girl period falsifiable test
lactate with hormone replacement therapy
there's definitely a question in there
there's two question marks but i'm not
totally sure what the question yeah is
she's like you're done guys you've been
doing it too long
um so i'm not sure what the question is
so i'm gonna go into the next one
um oh true yes
um the social nihilism described was
forebode by ian mcgilchrist long ago
queued up for you so there's a uh
youtube couple youtube links here i
believe it
um i'm not i'm not going to click on
these now but the idea that ian
mcgillcrist helped
saw this and helped predict it doesn't
surprise me not at all
a couple more here university of
michigan is hiring faculty
quote working at the intersection of
engineering social justice or common
good
including work that addresses
anti-racism inclusion equity or other
topics
for the department of mechanical
engineering
wow i can almost hear the bridge
creaking before it's collapsed that's
exactly what i was going to say
oh god um
yeah i mean look we've said this before
you can't do this
right to the extent that we are going to
sideline or hobble
every mechanical engineering school
we are going to make ourselves
vulnerable to our competitors
to the extent any school figures out how
not to do this while the others are
doing it it will come out ahead so
if you are in charge of one of these
schools figure out how to immunize it
you'll come out ahead your your
competitors will self-hobble
and at least we will still have some
school that knows how to build a bridge
or a building
or a dam right the last thing we want is
for everybody to forget
how to do that because they are
overwhelmed with
guilt about slaves they never owned yeah
uh one more question well actually i
guess it's a comment not a question
i may look fit but i identify as fat
these no trans fats labels on food
trigger me and make me fear a coming
genocide of trans fats like me
i i feel you yeah yeah i'm sorry
absolutely i'll do better will you do
better quality joke
can you can you promise me that you'll
do better than home
than you have been oh then meme yes no i
don't know
[Laughter]
i cannot promise you that i will do
better either than other people
or than i did before okay well
i guess that's it then i guess uh like
the cat is collapsed the dog is rolling
around
i think i think we're at the end we are
at that point in the afternoon
yeah um probably uh we will see you next
a week from today right after brett's
first
patreon conversation of the month on
next saturday
well i mean let's just put it this way
you should like you should subscribe
if you subscribe then you'll get an
alert when we're going on whenever that
would be
you could also uh follow us on twitter
that's another place you will find out
that we're going on so that would be
wise yeah you could
if if you want more of this uh we will
do our two-hour private q a tomorrow at
11 a.m pacific
it's so it's a much smaller group so
we're actually able to look at the chat
a little bit as it goes
um and it's it's been fun and
if you want to i've already got the
questions so
it's not if you sign up now you won't
have a question answered although
you might end up seeing anything you say
in chat
um if you want to talk unity
or game b or a coalition of the
reasonable or any of those related
concepts
then over to my patreon we are going to
have the first
discussion of the month on the first
saturday which is
the weekend today um
maybe that's it all right it's been fun
we'll see you next time
you